like I did the first ever rap show in
Kuwait and I was not allowed to cuss
fans had to remain seated the whole time
I couldn't dance not that I dance but I
do a little
twep there was none of that you know so
wait what what did it look like so it
was like you have a
Podium
stand do you have video get us the
video I've posted I've posted every show
I've ever done but um it was cool
imagine like imagine sort of like the
ballroom of a hotel okay it was kind of
that there was a stage and there were
seats and everyone had to remain seated
and me just being like obnoxious at that
time I was like [__] it's like I'm like
trying to rile him up I don't give a
[__] even though I did well with not
cursing but certain [__] gets out of
hand yeah type in yeah type in maybe uh
Russ Kuwait no oh yeah this is it yeah
see I'm still dancing I'm still hitting
my to I would have arrested you I would
have arrested you so the craziest thing
this is the here we go right look
everyone s everyone's sitting down and
they had they had like uh you know
officials from the government running
through the middle telling people to sit
down see someone stood up wow W and went
over to him told him that oh my God
crazy now the craziest thing that
happened during this show is in the
middle of my set I turn around at this
point like my manager was DJing DJ we I
he used to just plug in an ax to the
laptop when we just rocked out that's
like how we did like massive shows
yeah and um I turn around to him and I
have to stop the show because there's
like a uh there's a royal family member
who's like my daughters want pictures
the middle of the show middle of the set
crazy like and he's telling me he's like
yo this guy like he wants his daughters
to come up on stage and take pictures
like you got take I'm like I'm in I'm
like kind of busy yeah and so I just
didn't do it like wow yeah which it
ended up being fine like after the show
I don't know if it's in this clip but
after the show I talked to all of them
backstage and it was no I guess it's not
it's on my Instagram you talked to the
daughter's backstage no no no I talked
to the diplomats and the officials yeah
you pleading for your life at that point
or what is that like no it was fine it I
just feel like back then I you know I'm
just coasting on like it can't happen to
me it's all going to be fine I told them
this [__] yeah yeah when we were in uh
Abu Dhabi and uh we were doing the the
what is it called like the little run
through before the show we were just
doing sound check and [__] and I was
kind of like whing a little bit during
the sound check and the promoters were
getting a little nervous sure I can
imagine with your did you have to cut
anything out I ain't cut anything we
presented the list of what he couldn't
say and he violated and I was like yo
they're not going to arrest me I had the
same thought like why arrest me this is
a bad idea and uh but I remember them
getting nervous and then basically the
way that they positioned it was that
they
would go after the promoter I think it
was yeah like you know the promoter
would be worried about this they would
be responsible as well type it's also
yeah you want to go back right
especially when you know that the
audience is great that's that's what
they really have on you they got a great
sense of humor obviously don't talk
about Muhammad but like just it talking
about them like I posted a video I'm
making fun of them for the first 10 15
minutes of this like Nuance sh just
about their culture they love it Jesus
Christ we think they don't want to make
fun of themselves but they don't want to
laugh they do don't talk about Muhammad
talk about everybody else and you never
think that but it makes the most sense
when you pull back cuz it's like God is
God we're not God we're just people so
we can get made fun of you know what
traveling does and like I just brought
my dad on this trip that I just went on
he doesn't come around a lot and it was
so interesting to watch his perspective
sort of open but to that point it's like
when you travel to all these different
parts of the world what you realize
everyone is a human yeah everyone is
just a person I didn't see them as
humans either bro I agree so n dude you
know what I mean just white people just
white people no but it's like you know
you you you watch the news or you see
[__] you think that people are like yeah
Japanese people are this way they're
this and it's like bro everyone like has
the same you know
internal Japanese people are odd we got
to acknowledge that have you been in
Japan they're odd they're odd they're
the most odd just old them every sense
what do you think every sense they're
the most and I don't like how we can't
acknowledge it that's why we go cuz if
they was normal we wouldn't go I I think
Japan is [__] awesome I'll tell you
why say it's that
awesome I think Japanese people are
moving off of a ill Honor Code I [__]
with it you go out there there's no one
at the grocery store it's just an honor
code leave the money in the back ain't
that odd or good nobody's eating no I'm
saying no employees to like make sure
you're not stealing CU they just know
you're not going to steal [__] that's
odd that's awesome no it's awesome there
can be awesome the food that they make
is awesome it's odd that when I see two
people on a DAT I think odd has a
negative connotation but it is odd
listen there's some things there's some
things that are good there some things
that are bad my boy passed out in the
street shout out to Ben Ben had a pass
out in the street he woke up in Japan he
passed out in the street passed out in
the street blacked out passed out the
street woke up in the morning they had
his socks and shoes next to him and his
socks rolled up and stuffed into the
thing isn't that [__] incredible
that's odd cuz they was jerking off to
his feet that and that's the thing that
you didn't realize that's not that's not
you're
speculating see now is that proven
where's the footage can I
see Yo travel though your India clip was
crazy can you talk to me about that
whole experience bro India I felt like
Justin Bieber I was like oh this is like
a little taste crazy clip dude can we
show it it's rockar [__] yeah I don't
know if it's oh my God bro uh first of
all India is like the fastest growing
Market on Spotify right it's a massive
country that people are so loving so
supportive I've not seen people go that
hard for me like there's there's only so
many groups of people who really like
match that level of intensity man I went
to India second I landed there's people
at the airport which like I'm not used
to like fans L NBA championship [__]
yeah and like but respectful like
maintaining six feet not like yo yeah oh
they don't do that with us no like but I
don't it was just like whoo like y'all
are clearly Die Hard fans but it was
like so respectful and the shows were
[__] the level of passion of in
general just nuts bro it was bananas
like the two shows I did I did one in
Mumbai and Delhi and it was like oh man
this is [__] nuts out here I think I
saw the mumai clip I think it's nuts
priz pick.com guys and if you use the
promo code Schultz they will match your
initial deposit up to $100 so you put up
100 you get 100 for free why don't you
gamble with1 free dollars prix.com now
let's get back to the show